that let's bring in our panel ben
dominic publisher of the federalist
harold ford jr former tennessee
congressman ceo of empowerment and
inclusion capital and trey gowdy former
congressman from south carolina trey you
look at those numbers
you know
it's always tough to ask a poll question
about a piece of legislation as you know
there's a lot that goes into these
things that we don't often talk about
every nook and cranny but
you look at that you look at president
biden's position in these polls what do
you see
uh it's hard to be against roads and
bridges i i do wonder what else is in
the bill and of course the the people
being pulled weren't told that i i think
he remains personally popular but you
know brett
he is going to be held hostage by a
group called the squad that represents
about two percent of the country
but but but wants a hundred percent of
their agenda so he's getting ready to
not run into republicans they're tame
compared to what he's getting ready to
run into and i don't think he's going to
like the outcome you know harold we've
done a lot of time talking about
moderate democrats in the senate
including joe manchin and kirsten cinema
a mansion from west virginia the
democrat releasing a statement today
saying i have serious concerns about the
grave consequences facing west
virginians and every american family if
congress decides to spend another 3.5
trillion dollars given the current state
of the economic recovery it's simply
irresponsible to continue spending at
levels more suited to respond to a great
depression or great recession not an
economy that is on the verge of
overheating i urge my colleagues to
seriously consider this reality as this
budget process unfolds in the coming
weeks and months they
they need him they need that vote they
need cinema they need other moderate
democrats it doesn't sound like today
they have them
you know i would argue first thanks for
having me on i would argue the country
needs the voices of
the mansions and the cinemas and the
mark warner's and mark kelly's alike
i think the 3.5 trillion you heard it
just there that's not going to
uh likely not going to fly uh at that
level i think some of the the the
elements of this big package i like i
like some of the priorities but i was a
blue dog democrat when i was in congress
and we didn't support things that we
couldn't pay for so there are a lot of
things i want life i'd love to have more
houses and more cars than an airplane
but i can't afford them so congress has
to look at this in a way that makes the
most sense the president said it well
the other night when he said
the one trillion dollar package is what
america wants
if you're able to craft a second package
that america wants
i think it'll pass now there are
concerns that nancy pelosi won't be able
to work with the squad and i hear my
friend trey gowdy talk the way he spoke
just now
you know nancy pelosi got the health
care package passed for president obama
i think she will find a way
to get this bill passed too it's needed
when you consider china what they're
spending when you consider the local
needs in communities this is a smart
bill and i hope we take the win in the
house and the senate and sign it for the
country one of the things that happens
with this legislation is what's called a
vote-a-rama and these are amendments
that everybody votes on republicans put
some up democrats put them up one of
them
that did pass
was tom cotton's amendment about
critical race theory take a listen to
him
sadly today some want to replace our
founding principles with an un-american
ideology called critical race theory
they want to teach our children that
america is on a good nation but a racist
nation those teachings are wrong and our
tax dollars should not support them my
amendment will ensure that federal funds
aren't used to indoctrinate kids as
young as pre-k
to hate america
our future depends on the next
generation of kids loving america and
loving each other
as fellow citizens no matter their race
so that amendment the stop uh crt act
introduced by cotton ben uh did pass and
as opposed to the last time
they did not wipe all the amendments
clean
and manchin said he wasn't going to vote
for that this time
it's interesting to think about the
concerns of a working american family
today
is there concern about these trillion
dollar packages or is it about the
strength of the dollar their ability to
pay for eggs without having to spend
another 40 cents
or or the kind of things that their
children are learning that they just
learned about because of having to have
this remote learning here and zoom
packages and the like are they concerned
more about the build back better plan or
are they concerned about whether the cdc
is going to respond to potential
pressure from teachers unions to maybe
roll back in person learning in this in
this fall experience i think the
concerns of the american people are very
much out of line with the concerns of
this white house at the moment and
that's only going to be a problem that
continues to increase i believe in the
months ahead creating all manner of
problems as we head into an election